bien d'accord je vous remercie donc
c'est fini parce que j'étais un petit
minutes que vous délirez oui je rappelle
vieilles canailles vienne il est cuit
sur nos écrans depuis mercredi et qui
est un véritable chef-d'oeuvre réaliser
du cinéma français un peu plus cher
brice et il faut y aller parce que je
crois qu'il est bien bien en place
devant et le pas devant j'allais dire
derrière les deux les deux grands films
américains parce qu on est obligé en
france de passer toujours devant un
derrière les américains mentant au
cinéma comme ailleurs mais enfin ça n'a
pas d'importance mais comme le film
français
il était à la bonne place merci beaucoup
et l'américain google
oui mais bruno je voulais vraiment que
marc tixador michel selon michel seurat
du tout que je connais bien c'est
beaucoup parce que je suis touché ses
seins professionnels de première c'est
la csu recueillent bref vous avez fait
là tout à l'heure c'est à dire à mon
avis pas admissible au fait que je vais
le lâcher pour la paix non mais c'est
moi qui voulais vous demander pardon et
la profession je voulais que je me
débarrasse de vaud png non merci
un petit chèque comme je sais qu'il faut
pas dépasser les 1000 francs ou non mais
on déborde vous coule voilà c'est 999
francs par jeu ses passions que le oui
oui voila merci de vos cadeaux il faut
rendre l'antenne alors c'est bien mon
émission ce soir il faut pas qu'on
déborde dans un petit quart d'heure je
savais pas qu'il fallait payer ont fait
penser genre de réflexion dans un petit
quart d'heure rappelle-t-on
bernard giraudeau c'est l'histoire de
deux anciennes vedettes de la télévision
aux convertis justement dans
l'escroquerie le tout décidément je
rappelle le 22h30 taratata avec donc
négligent vers 23h45 non je ne peux pas
le dire dernier journal en compagnie de
rémi roche demain à 7h50 gérard leclerc
retrouvera mon confrère alain duhamel
qui parlera de son dernier livre les
peurs française après le paris dakar et
le journal des courses lanata de la
météo de ne pas écrouer elle va être
content d'avoir deux bogeys
dans ce journal nathalie qui vous
parlera d'un sérieux renforcements
d'erreurs dans le quart nord-ouest du
pays à demain matin remercie beaucoup
pour soir